- [Man] Why do you hate Fridays so much?
- Because I hate people
that live their lives for the weekend.
(slow bright music)
I'm blown away by people
celebrating the end of the week.
Like the weekend is your
escape from your reality.
It breaks my heart my friends
like live for Friday night.
Like they know they get the,
like Monday morning's the worst.
To live your life where
you love Friday night,
Saturday and Sunday and
despise Monday through Thursday
or Friday morning is devastating to me
because you're wasting
too much of your life.
Like 50% of your entire life is predicated
on what you do at work like it's
a just such a huge
percentage of one's life.
And I'm trying to pt
pressure on the conversation
to say if you love Friday that much
then you need to really look
at Monday through Thursday.
And see if you can do something about it.
Sunday night I'm like chomping.
I'm like a fighter before a fight
like in the dressing room.
Like I can't like I try
to go to sleep early
on Sunday 'cause I can't wait for Monday
'cause I get to put my jersey on.
This is not your grand pappy's life.
- Yeah.
- We have the internet.
You can make shit happen.
You can build businesses or side hustles
take less money and like
live a little more humbly
to set up your next 50 years.
So many of you are so
hungry for short term,
short term gains.
Like maximizing the job
that paid you $3,000 more
but it's not as fun but
you want that $3,000.
For what?
For a new iPhone, for what?
You get to live life one time.
I'm talking about
if you genuinely dislike
what you do so much
that you bagged for Friday.
Listen I lived 12 years of this
and definitely at least nine.
I just don't understand
why people relegate into losing mentality,
and just thinking they can't.
You can't because you want to be on
the bowling team or softball
or play video games.
That's why you can't.
There's plenty of time.
Get shit done.
The thought that is so
many people's work lives
which will be the
disproportionate percentage
of how they live their
lives breaks my heart.
If I can get one person to
be like fuck he's right.
Like what the hell am I doing here?
Please do not waste
the next five, 10, 15, 20, 30 years
of your life and allocate 30, 40, 50, 60 %
of your time to something that you cheer
to end each and every week.
If you genuinely celebrate Friday
you need to rethink your
entire fucking game.
(slow bright music)